and just because somebody else can't see
your vision doesn't mean that it's not a
powerful vision for you but if you don't
love what you're doing run for your life
we need to stop whining about what isn't
happening what we don't have what we
can't do what somebody didn't do the
truth will cut through all the drama all
the misunderstanding all the hurt all
the pain all the memories I got
something for you refuse to fail it's
like being wrong it's almost a fatal
disease or something like it a drop will
die on the spot if we have to say I was
wrong be authentic be authentic my car
got a name I say Gracie how you doing
this morning come on we go in traveler
also being really clear about what it is
you want talk to yourself about it
clarity is a gift and it grows and
develops through practice she's an
American inspirational speaker author
life coach lawyer and television
personality she's known for her books
and appearances on The Oprah Winfrey
Show she's considered one of the hundred
most spiritually influential living
people in the world
she's Ian's life and scent and here are
her top ten rules for success three
things I want you to do to nurture your
vision I want you to affirm it every day
affirm it every day and don't affirm it
is I'm trying I wish I want to I am let
me hear you say I am
I am every single day I am is the
creative force of the universe whatever
you attach I am too you will become you
know people say I'm broke
I'm single no I'm waiting for my ideal
mate to present himself to me in a way
that I recognize
whatever you attach I am - I'm confused
no I am awaiting clarity in this moment
so affirm your vision every day and just
because somebody else can't see your
vision doesn't mean that it's not a
powerful vision for you
here's another key for you never judge
your clarity on how other people respond
did you hear me think I'll say what you
doing you crazy why are you doing that
you can't do that who tell you you could
do that who do you think you are I love
that one who do you think you are me
affirm your vision clarify your vision
know what you're doing why you're doing
it and how you're doing it day by day
moment by moment and sometime the how
only shows up on a need-to-know basis
don't wait for the how until you start
pursuing your vision you understand
don't wait for the house sometimes you
just have to walk blindly but if you
just do your vision every single day
putting one foot in front of the other
committed to your desires being obedient
walking through your fears the vision
will unfold much grander than you could
have ever even imagined or asked for so
this is what I say to support your
vision instead of begging for it
pleading for it
pray oh god please open your please God
please
oh god please please God
whoa holla you holla do be still
let your daily spiritual practice be one
of stillness and listening listen for
the instruction instead of begging for
the direction listen be still I don't
care what it is that you're doing in
this world I know many of you involved
in the government here and we have so
many elected officials and people who
are serving the world in so many ways
but if you don't love what you're doing
run for your life
run for your life if five day if three
days out of the five you do in your work
you complain more than you bless run for
your life if you're continually looking
at what you don't have and what people
aren't doing as opposed to look at how
blessed you are to be in a position to
run for your life
you got cooties and you need to run for
your life so I have this thing that I've
been promoting called no whining
Wednesday's Wednesday
you cannot whine complain or criticize
and be like well what is whining
whatever you think it is don't do it and
every time you do it you have to put a
quarter in a jar if you whine about
anything
I can't untie my to mean you want why
don't you what heavy huh every one of
them will cost you a quarter or
complaining why don't you why do you
always how come you I always say never
cost you a quarter then last week I had
people send me pictures of their jaws or
quarters oh my god ha ha ha but what
they said to me also was this was
wonderful because I was never
ever aware of how much whining and
complaining and criticizing I do now
I've got mother's doing it with their
children so Wednesday is no whining
Wednesday we need to practice that we
need to stop whining about what isn't
happening what we don't have what we
can't do what somebody didn't do we got
to get it clean in 2014 no whining no
complaining no criticizing keep it
simple the truth will cut through all
the drama all the misunderstanding all
the hurt all the pain all the memories
keep it simple I don't care how long you
been with Fifi or boo boo if they leave
you it's not because something's wrong
with you they ain't the one for you keep
it simple
you got laid off from your job there's
another divine opportunity waiting for
you to keep it simple you lost your
house well in your father's house there
are many mansions just hang around long
enough keep it simple the path to
greatness order vision trust faith a
good piece of chocolate and simplicity I
got something for you refuse to fail
refuse
just refuse to fail and if what you're
doing looks like it's gonna move you
towards failure do something else will
be look at me
refuse to fail I refuse I refuse to fail
now that may mean that I have to walk
barefoot
it may mean I have to sleep in the park
it may mean that I have to ask for help
it may mean that I have to give
something up it may mean that I have to
stop but I refuse to fail we like to be
right yeah it's like being wrong is
almost a fatal disease or something like
it a drop will die on the spot if we
have to say I was wrong you know so so
if we look around and anybody challenges
us it will give up what we believe so
here is one of the things that I learned
on my journey to peace I don't need your
agreement I'm asking for your support
I don't need your room not gonna get
people to agree with what you know in
here cuz they don't know that they in
there never judge your clarity based on
somebody else's response when you clear
your clear head to your clarity and if
people look like they doubt you close
your eyes be authentic be authentic many
people don't even know what that means
it means that you're clear about who you
are it's you're clear about your purpose
your protocols and your plans you're
clear about what you're up to and you
speak your the truth of that all the
time be authentic means you're in
integrity that what you think what you
say what you feel and what you do all
matter
I know that's hard in Washington cuz
they're just some shoes you can't tell
out here but we want to do the best that
we can and when you can't pray about it
but be authentic so many of us don't
allow people to know who we are as I
travel around this country I meet
country people all over the country who
are suffering in silence because they're
not authentic about what they need what
they want what they're doing what
they're experiencing let's clean up our
mouths how we say what we say and who we
say it to do you know you can talk
yourself into trouble huh a lot easier
than you can talk yourself out of it but
if you become mindful about what you're
speaking it'll be a lot easier to handle
some of the things that come up in your
life with speaking years and years and
years ago I learned a secret I used to
open my pocketbook my purse I'd get
right down over and I'd say fill
yourself with divine substance right now
are you look at all that abundance just
pouring down right I I named everything
and I speak to everything my car got a
name I say Gracie how you doing this
morning come on we going traveling my
house got a name Villanova the big
vision a mindful of my mouth because I
know that what comes out of my mouth
must be created everything begins with a
word so we even want to stop speaking
about how horrible our children are
doing or how bad people are doing or how
bad things in here what his affirmation
oh my I can hardly wait to see the good
that's gonna come out of this no matter
what it is as opposed to Ewing using our
power to continue to affirm what's wrong
what's broke what ain't working what's
not happening how horrible it is let's
speak life into things let's speak life
into our children let's speak life into
our families into our relationships I
can't tell you the number of people who
write me and say I need you to help me
with my crazy family well they're your
family I don't even know that kind of
crazy you got over there this is just
what I'd be thinking and then I blessed
my head so that that thought will go
away but what if we started saying wow I
know it looks like boo-boo my cousin is
having difficulty right now but I see a
brighter day for you
it's what Emmett Fox call goal keying
where you key something up with the
radiant richness of what you wanted to
be as opposed to a firmament as it is
right now as it is right now so we want
to clean up our mouths and what we say
about each other imagine that you have
24 hours a day for how many years how
much of that time do you give just for
you well you just sit and be present
with you self-care and self nurturing
also being really clear about what it is
you want talk to yourself about it talk
to somebody you care about about it hear
your own voice and honor your own
feeling
and be good to you be clear about who
you are and what you're up to at any
given point in time be clear about what
matters to you what you value what you
will do what you won't do what you can
do and what you can't do
be clear clarity is a gift and it grows
and develops through practice be clear
be clear about who you are many many
years ago when I first started doing
this work and I was writing I wrote a
little purple book called acts of faith
and the book had a life all his own and
I was running all over speaking and
talking about acts of faith and and
stuff and and and making money on the
book of speaking for fifty dollars and
three hundred dollars and two hundred
dollars I had to get clear cuz I had all
five hundred dollars worth of clothes it
was not profitable but I had to get
clear and Dennis Kimbrell said this to
me right in the halls of the old
Convention Center he said Yamcha be
clear about what you are are you a
writer who speaks or a speaker who
writes sometimes when we do multiple
things we throw them all together and we
dis each and we master none be clear
about who you are about what you do what
you're up to what is your primary cause
of action and call to action you gotta
be clear and listening to what Dennis
Kimbrell said to me was I a speaker who
writes or a writer who speaks I said
well I
that's something that I do but that's
not who I be who you be you've got to
get clear about who you be because being
is an internal state it's not about
doing it's what drives you
what elevates you what you would do
every single day of your life for the
rest of your life whether you got paid
or not
that's who you be what matters to you
that's who you be what you value that's
who you be and so many of us are clear
about what we have to do but not clear
about who we be as we're doing it
because some of us want to serve people
and we mean it in a wet cat on any given
Sunday who get clear about who you be
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because Jessica Salter asks
us to if there's anyone that you would
like us to feature please leave a
comment below I also love to know which
of the 10 rules hit you the hardest had
the greatest impact on your life and why
leave it in the comments and we'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon bye